the details of the final DLC pack for
Hyrule warriors has been revealed today
so if you don't want to be spoiled you
should tune out now cuz i'm gonna show
you all the things the boss pack dlc for
hyrule warriors set to arrive on march
12 for three bucks may seem innocent
enough i mean it as gannon as a playable
character which is cool but there's a
little more to it than meets the eye if
you've got a mind to pick up the dlc
you'll also be getting access to a
secret playable character if you've got
the skills to unlock it if you've ever
dreamed of playing thousands of poses
with gigantic cuckoo that's now a
completely viable thing you can do well
in video game at least as a huge and I
need huge version of the chickens from
The Legend of Zelda you can do
impressive amount of damage and summon a
bevy of smaller car keys to attack on
your behalf you do have to unlock an a
rank of gannan third survival mission to
unlock the enormous foul however let me
know down in the comments who you reckon
would win in a fight gannon or a
gigantic cut you stay tuned to gamespot
for all the latest gaming and chicken
related news